est rentré ça m'a rendu plus intolérante
alors par mois elle c'est la dimension
je voulais vous poser justement délirer
autour d'un dessert que j'ai appelé la
pêche
la balade je voulais vraiment montrer
que le monde d'après qui serait aussi
dynamique et tony que le monde d'avant
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
par la voix de son président la russie
annonce un premier vaccin contre le
coronavirus il procure une immunité
durable assure vladimir poutine scouts
nigré c'est son nom sera produit dès le
mois de septembre pour une mise en
circulation le 1er janvier prochain une
vingtaine de pays seraient déjà sur les
rangs de son côté l'om ait ce rappel il
faut suivre des procédures rigoureuses
pour homologuer un vaccin au liban une
minute de silence a été observée à 18h06
une semaine jour pour jour après la
terrible explosion qui a fait 171
victimes et la démission du gouvernement
n'apaisent pas pour autant les esprits
les libanais manifestent toujours contre
la classe politique dirigeante qu'ils
accusent de corruption
hier hassan diab et ses ministres ont
jeté l'épongé le pays continue de
s'enfoncer dans la crise politique
les tensions en biélorussie la
réélection d'alexandre loukachenko à la
tête du pays suscite de la colère
l'union européenne dénonce le manque
d'équité de ces élections et menacent de
prendre des sanctions
hier soir un manifestant a trouvé la
mort plusieurs ont été blessés d'autres
arrêtées lors d'un rassemblement
la principale opposante du président
sortant svetlana tirano sky a revendiqué
la victoire et réclame son départ elle
s'est réfugiée en ligue b
[Musique]
il est 20h heure de paris bonsoir et
bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez sur
arte france
moscou at il remporté la course au
vaccin contre locaux vides 19 dans une
allocution télévisée
vladimir poutine a déclaré que la russie
avait développé le premier sérum contre
la maladie un vaccin officiellement
enregistrés par le ministère russe de la
santé a regardé notre community oignons
d'après ce que je sais ce matin un
premier vaccin contre la nouvelle
infection de coronavirus a été
enregistré pour la première fois dans le
monde
une chaire serre
[Musique]
et les réactions ne se sont pas fait
attendre on a vu celle de l'om est ce
qu'ils appellent à la prudence berlin de
son côté émet des doutes sur la qualité
l'efficacité et la sécurité du vaccin
russe un vaccin qui a été élaboré dans
le nord ouest de moscou plus précisément
dans cette usine à zelenograd à celle
usine bino farm c'est seulement ici que
sera fabriquer le vaccin par la société
sistema on écoute son président cette
unité de production a déjà lancé le
processus de fabrication du vaccin alors
qu'il est le volume de production est de
près de 1,5 million de doses par an nous
comprenons parfaitement que c'est
insuffisant
et c'est pour cette raison que nous
continuons à investir dans leurs
équipements et l'augmentation des
volumes de production
le premier lot de vaccin est déjà prêt à
être livré dans les régions de la russie
c'est l'état qui décidera des priorités
dans sa distribution
mais d'après ce que je comprends les
premiers à pouvoir bénéficier du vaccin
seront les médecins car ils sont en
première ligne de la lutte contre la
pandémie et ils sont les plus exposés
aux risques de contagion et l'annoncent
russe intervient alors que l'on recense
plus de 20 millions 2,99 dans le monde
selon un comptage réalisé par l' agence
france-presse
plus de la moitié se trouve en amérique
et quatre cas sur dix se trouvent aux
états unis ou au brésil
toujours en amérique la colombie vient
de passer la barre des 13 mille morts en
europe la finlande annonce la mise en
place d'une quarantaine strictes pour
tout voyageur provenant de pays à risque
autre information la nouvelle zélande
vient de détecter quatre nouveaux 4
coronavirus après 102 jours sans aucune
contamination est la première ministre
vient d'annoncer le confinement de la
plus grande ville du pays auckland
et puis en france les autorités
s'inquiètent de l'évolution de la
situation sanitaire de ces dernières
semaines une inquiétude formulée par
jean castex en visite à la grande motte
et au chu
peut lier avec olivier ferrand que le
premier ministre est revenu sur les
chiffres et les risques d'une reprise
épidémique dans l'hexagone jean castex
souhaite notamment généraliser le plus
possible le port du masque à l'extérieur
interdiction également des
rassemblements de plus de cinq mille
personnes prolongé jusqu'à la fin
octobre
vous riez la situation liée à l'épidémie
de covin 19 s'est dégradée au cours des
derniers jours le nombre des
hospitalisations
huit cents par semaine et d'admission un
service de réanimation cents par semaine
repartent à la hausse au plan national
25 nouveau cluster sont identifiés
chaque jour contre environ 5 par jour
il y à trois semaines je le dis
aujourd'hui avec une forme de gravité si
nous ne réagissons pas collectivement
nous nous exposons un risque élevé de
reprise épidémique qui sera difficile à
contrôler et pour en parler nous sommes
avec enrique casalino chef du service
des urgences de l'hôpital bichat à paris
enrique casalino merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors jean
castex a donc annoncé le renforcement de
ses mesures sanitaires avec notamment le
souhaite généraliser le port du masque
en extérieur c'est une nécessité absolue
selon vous aujourd'hui
je pense qu'aujourd'hui ce qui nécessité
absolue c'est que chacun d'entre nous
chaque citoyen comprennent que lui
les amateurs de prévention port du
masque le respect des distances de
sécurité
un mètre minimum se laver les mains ne
pas s'exposer inutilement mis dans des
endroits fermés ni dans des endroits
ouverts avait foule
évitez les endroits surchargé avec une
forte densité de personnes
si nous sommes capables individuellement
et collectivement de faire ça nous
éviterons la possibilité d'une nouvelle
vague épidémique
si nous ne nous sommes pas capables
collectivement de respecter ses règles
de fonctionnement et des bonnes
conduites bonne conduite dans le sens de
prévention d'une épidémie nous aurons
des difficultés nous connaîtrons une
nouvelle période difficile dans les
semaines qui viennent
est ce que ces chiffres oui est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous vous êtes inquiets
ou alors finalement avec le brassage est
liée à la période estivale
cette situation était attendu oui vous
avez raison cette situation pouvait être
attendu c'était prévisible qu'il y
aurait un relâchement mais ce que nous
constatons c'est que le relâchement a
été peut-être plus important qu'on ne le
pensait et que ça allait se craindre au
retour des vacances avec ce brassage de
populations qui se déplacent du nord
vers le sud de l'est vers l'ouest et
vice versa c'est mobilise cette grande
mobilité de notre population
cette diminution d'une certaine rigueur
dans le respect des mesures pourrait
nous mettre en grande difficulté dès le
mois de septembre est peut-être aller
vers une vague épidémique ou une
nouvelle poussée épidémique au cours du
mois d'octobre ou de novembre
il ne faut pas penser que parce que nous
voyons une courbe un peu plate
actuellement nous sommes rassurés c'est
une question d'échelle
il faudrait éliminer la période de mars
à briller pour voir que dans la courbe
nous avons multiplié par deux ou par
trois le nombre de cas par semaine
ces deux ou trois dernières semaines
donc nous devons rester vigilants
justement quelle est la situation très
concrètement actuelle dans les autres
hôpitaux français notamment à l'hôpital
bichat qu'est ce que vous observez ce
que nous observons dans la plupart des
hôpitaux
c'est à nouveau des cas de convives
pour vous donner une échelle et celle de
mon hôpital
nous avions eu des semaines une deux
semaines pendant laquelle il n'y avait
pas un seul cas maintenant nous avons
tous les jours 3 4 4 toujours
hospitalisés 1
mais vous voyez il ya quand même une
différence et quels profils parce qu'on
a beaucoup parlé pendant cette période
de vacances
des jeunes de clusters à cause de jeunes
qui se rassemblaient les gens qui
viennent aujourd'hui dans les hôpitaux
ils sont plutôt jeunes ou alors ce sont
des gens âgés comme lors du pic de la
crise sanitaire
nour actuellement ce sont plutôt des
personnes jeunes mais il faut pas
oublier que l'épidémie avait été aussi
une épidémie chez des personnes jeunes
au début de l'épidémie c'est à dire il
faudrait regarder les chiffres de fin
janvier début février et que l'épidémie
on suit à frapper là où il y avait la
population la plus fragile c'est à dire
les personnes âgées seulement après mais
c'est c'est ce qui va t'arriver
lorsque les gens rentreront des vacances
les personnes jeunes et les moins jeunes
ils iront revoir leurs parents ils iront
revoir leurs grands parents parce que
c'est normal parce que nous avons tous
envie de vivre en société de voir les
autres nos proches et c'est à ce moment
là que de façon inconsciente mais
j'attire leurs intentions et leurs
responsabilités sur ça ils vont pouvoir
contaminé des personnes fragiles et ce
ne sont pas que des personnes très âgées
ça peut être des personnes plus jeunes
mais qui ont un bien être qui ont une
hypertension qui ont un problème de
santé et ses populations se sont aussi
un très haut risque alors la question
des tests a également abordé par jean
castex 600 mille tests sont effectués
chaque semaine en ce moment est-ce qu'on
pourrait finalement rendre ces tests
encore plus accessible selon vous je
pense qu'aujourd'hui nous faisons déjà
beaucoup de tests et ces tests servent à
isoler faire un million de tests si
derrière ça il n'y a aucune attitude ça
ne sert à rien on peut continuer à faire
les 600 ou 700 mille tests par semaine
que nous faisons actuellement
mais ce qui est important c'est que
chaque fois qu'il ya quelqu'un qui est
positif
il est des consignes précises que des
équipes interviennent auprès de tous ses
contacts qu'on continue à dépister ces
contacts et que tout le monde ait des
consignes précises de respect d'un
musulman pour éviter que l'inflation
continue à se
minés merci beaucoup henrique casalino
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes chef des urgences
de l'hôpital bichat à paris
et les conséquences de la crise
sanitaire se font toujours ressentir sur
l'activité des entreprises si la reprise
économique se poursuit en juillet elle
se fait à un rythme plus modéré que le
mois dernier selon un rapport publié
hier par la banque de france a les
explications tout de suite en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au liban le peuple maintient la pression
malgré la démission du gouvernement et
cette information de reuters ne devrait
pas arranger les choses
elles selon lagence les dirigeants ont
été prévenus en juillet des risques dans
le port est les libanais touché depuis
plusieurs mois par une crise économique
sans précédent le bilan 171 morts et des
milliers de blessés
et pour leur rendre hommage les églises
et les mosquées du pays ont lancé
simultanément l'appel à la prière à
18h06 l'heure exacte de l'explosion qui
a dévasté la capitale
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
nous avons un groupe d'ingénieurs qui
fait un sondage pour savoir comment nous
pouvons aider les personnes qui ont été
touchés par l'explosion
nous offrons de la nourriture des kits
d'hygiène et nous avons un groupe de
bénévoles qui se vend à l'intérieur des
habitations endommagées pour offrir leur
aide nos coeurs ne peuvent pas supporter
une telle dévastation dans le pays nous
avons grandi et vécu la maison dans
laquelle nous avons grandi a été démoli
tous nos rêves ont été brisées c'est une
dévastation émotionnelle la démission du
gouvernement est une grande mascarade
même après la démission qui nous
dédommagera pour nos vies nos clients et
nos entreprises
heureusement aucun de nos enfants n'a
été blessé non seulement le gouvernement
devrait démissionner mais tous les
dirigeants devraient le faire celui qui
est au sommet devrait démissionner
michel aoun
alors quels sont les scénarios
maintenant au liban qui dirige le pays
aujourd'hui un vrai changement politique
est il possible éléments de réponse avec
amine alias professeur d'histoire de
sciences politiques à l'université
libanaise mais qui dirige le pays
vraiment c'est une grande question de
prix 30 ans il y a on a à tricoter au
liban sous la tutelle syrienne
on a tricoté à un système de de mafia
est vraiment c'est lui qui qui qui qui
dirige le pays
et hier il était clairement sur un
diable il a bien déclaré dans son
manifeste de démission que la mafia au
liban elle est beaucoup plus forte que
l'état et ça c'est grave
la question c'est pas une question d'un
gouvernement ou vraiment c'est un réseau
qui est petit est très bien fort qui est
très bien qui est qui et qui prend très
bien en main les rênes du pouvoir rpt du
mans et il est capable de se reproduire
de se reproduire à nouveau avec avec les
élections législatives alors je ne pense
pas qu'il y aura un vrai changement avec
le la même loi d'élections avec les
mêmes la même mentalité de gestion du
pays avec la mentalité même d'aider des
citoyens libanais et des détails à
présent sur les deux mille sept cent
cinquante tonnes de nitrate d'ammonium
qui ont provoqué la terrible double
explosion elles sont arrivées en 2013
par voie maritime sur un cargo sous
pavillon moldave le capitaine russe du
navire boris pougo chef explique que
lors de son amarrage le bateau était
dans un état de délabrement avancé
bloqué pendant un an par les autorités
libanaises est les marins sont
finalement autorisé à partir en 2014
c'est lors de cette année que la
cargaison et stockés dans un entrepôt
puis progressivement oublié
écoutez le capitaine du navire qui
raconte son arrivée dans le port avant
d'entrer dans le port nous avons indiqué
le contenu de la cargaison et sa classe
conformément à la classification établie
par l'organisation maritime
internationale
l'entrée nous a été autorisé un pilote
de port est venu notre navire a été mis
en rade plus tard un pilote de pan est
arrivé il nous a aidé à entrer dans le
port où nous avons un marais notre
navire on nous a demandé mais je ne me
souviens pas de qui exactement
il lui a dit l'entrée au port de
beyrouth est interdit aux navires
transportant ce type de cargaison
comment avez vous pu entrer qu'est ce
que j'en sais moi et je répondu nous
avons fourni tous les papiers indiqué le
contenu de la cargaison lieu de départ
et la destination
le service de contrôle des navires du
port de beyrouth a accepté ces données
et nous a envoyé un pilote de port qui
nous a aidé à entrer dans le port est
amarré la vie
je marchais sur la verge dans le port et
j'ai vu un autre navire décharger sa
cargaison de nitrate d'ammonium puis
demander pourquoi ce navire décharger sa
cargaison
alors que le nôtre n'avait pas été
autorisée à le faire on m'a répondu que
la cargaison du navire en question avait
une concentration de nitrates d'ammonium
plus basse que la nôtre la concentration
de la substance de notre cargaison
dépassé les limites autorisées par
conséquent contrairement au nôtre le
navire en question a été autorisés à
décharger en revanche sur le territoire
libanais il était interdit de décharger
une cargaison dont la teneur en nitrate
d'ammonium était aussi élevée que la
nôtre
ouais ce qu'on m'a dit cela veut dire
qu'ils étaient parfaitement au courant
manifestation aujourd'hui à ramallah
pour demander la libération d'un des
leaders du mouvement de boycott d'israël
le mouvement bds boycott
désinvestissement sanctions plusieurs
dizaines de personnes se sont
rassemblées devant les bureaux de la
délégation de l'allemagne je vous le
rappelle qui assure la présidence
tournante de l'union européenne
objectif des manifestants demandé à lui
eu de faire pression pour obtenir la
libération d'un des leaders du mouvement
dans les territoires palestiniens
mahmoud nawa déjà été arrêté le 30
juillet à son domicile de ramallah par
l'armée israélienne
puis il a été transféré dans une prison
en israël où il n'a pas pu rencontrer
ses avocats
nous sommes ici pour dire à l'allemagne
en tant que président du conseil de
l'union européenne qu'il est temps de
faire pression sur israël pour qu'il
respecte les droits des palestiniens en
vertu du droit international
il ne suffit pas de condamner les crimes
de guerre et les crimes contre
l'humanité israélien il est temps de
prendre des sanctions légales et ciblées
l'union européenne est le plus grand
bloc commercial qui a des relations
commerciales avec israël
ils ont beaucoup de poids pour forcer
israël à respecter les droits des
palestiniens au moins il devrait
défendre les défenseurs des droits
humains palestiniens comme mahmoud yahou
aja et faire pression sur israël pour
qu'il le libère immédiatement et sans
condition
ce matin emmanuel macron a tenu un
conseil de défense le chef de l'état a
annoncé que les mesures de sécurité pour
les français au sahel seront renforcées
après la mort dans l'attaqué dimanche au
niger de huit personnes dont six jeunes
humanitaires français l attaque qui
s'est produite à 60 km de la capitale
niamey elle n'a pas été revendiqué mais
le parquet antiterroriste a ouvert une
enquête à paris elle sur place une vaste
opération de ratissage a été lancée pour
retrouver les responsables
l association avec ted a décidé de
porter plainte
on regarde ces annonces des manuels
macron via twitter j'ai décidé de
renforcer les mesures de sécurité pour
nos ressortissants dans la région
nous poursuivons l'action pour éradiquer
les groupes terroristes
avec l'appui renforcé de nos partenaires
nous mettons tout en oeuvre pour
soutenir les familles des victimes et
répondre à l' attaque qui a coûté la vie
à six de nos compatriotes et à deux
nigériens membres de l' ong acted ces
six jeunes témoignait d'un engagement
remarquable pour les populations
une attaque qui a provoqué l'indignation
de la population nigérienne écouter ces
quelques réactions au vu de l'horreur du
crime qui a été commis au vu de la
jeunesse de sécurité victimes dont la
plupart
vraiment je pense que les autorités
nigériennes en relation avec les
autorités françaises américaines doivent
mettre les bouchées doubles pour trouver
les coupables afin de les mettre à la
disposition de la justice c'est inquiète
tellement répugnante
nous exhortons les autorités à tout
faire pour mettre la main sur ces
criminels pour éviter qu'ils ne
commettent d'autres meurtres seront
peut-être les prochaines cibles ce sont
de jeunes étrangers qui ont été tués que
dieu aide les autorités à les rattraper
et à les châtier
nous allons beaucoup prier pour les
victimes et pour que dieu nous aide à
rattraper et emprisonner les meurtriers
cdc nous accable tous et tout le niger
les pleurs s'est dit que abba
journaliste écrivain nigérien est
intervenu sur notre antenne sur le sujet
écoutez son analyse ce qu'on peut
comprendre cette annonce c'est la
volonté peut être d'augmenter les
effectifs de la force bataille qui avait
été déjà et augmentent et au sortir de
la conférence de pau qui a réuni en
janvier dernier en france est le présent
mâcon et ses homologues du g6 elle
depuis le sommet de pau il a été mis en
place à niamey justement un état-major
de coordination entre la force marquant
et l'armée nationale qui a permis
d'améliorer justement à l'efficacité des
opérations sur le terrain il faut
poursuivre sans doute cette coordination
opérationnelle et favoriser surtout la
montée en puissance de la force du g5
sel il est évident pour moi que même si
la france renforce ses effectifs et ses
moyens ça ne se fera pas tant que les
armées nationales n'auront pas le niveau
de capacité suffisante pour leur
permettre d'assurer la sécurité et tant
qu'on n'aura pas articuler la question
de la réponse sécuritaire avec les
questions de développement et les
questions de gouvernance pas le sexe la
situation en biélorussie inquiète la
commission européenne paris berlin et
londres condamnent la répression après
les manifestations contre la réélection
d'alexandre loukachenko à la tête du
pays
de son côté le président biélorusse
dénonce des pressions venues de
l'extérieur depuis londres varsovie et
prague
par ailleurs sa principale arrive à lui
demande de céder le pouvoir
svetlana tsira nouveau sky a quitté le
pays pour se réfugier en lituanie le
récit de france pâtissier vite chez de
romain loeffel nouvelle nuit de violence
ont bien la russie depuis la réélection
contestée d'alexandre loukachenko ce
dimanche pour un sixième mandat de
président des milliers de manifestants
font face aux forces de l'ordre
[Musique]
non
les biélorusses qui remettent en cause
la légitimité de ces élections
comme vous pouvez voir ce qu'il se passe
ils arrêtent des gens qui ne font rien
je pense donc que les élections ont été
injustes au maximum car pourquoi le
président qui a obtenu 80 % des voix ah
si terriblement peur de son propre
peuple
les affrontements sont violents la
police faisant usage de matraques de
grenades à explosion et de gaz
lacrymogènes
le ministère de l'intérieur le confirme
une personne a trouvé la mort et une
dizaine d'autres ont été blessées depuis
le début des manifestations au moins
3000 personnes ont été arrêtées et 39
personnes blessées et hospitalisées
plusieurs journalistes interpellés en
marge de ces événements ont été libérées
selon l'ambassade russe à minsk
alexandre loukachenko dénonce des
manifestations manipulé depuis
l'étranger il voulait mettre le feu dans
le centre de minsk pour capri depuis ce
disperser les choses brûlé dans tout
minsk bien sûr ils n'y sont pas parvenus
ils essaient de créer du désordre chez
nous j'ai prévenu qu'il n'y aurait pas
de révolution de maidan comme en ukraine
même si certains le souhaitent
les gens ont besoin de se calmer
l'opposante svet la nati canaux ce
qu'aia dénonce des fraudes massives
la désormais ex candidate à l'élection
présidentielle a finalement pris la
décision de quitter la biélorussie pour
se réfugier en lituanie j'ai pris une
décision très difficile
j'ai pris cette décision seule personne
ne m'a influencé en aucune façon ni mes
amis ni ma famille ni l'équipe de
campagne ni mon mari sergueï tikhonov
ski je sais que beaucoup me condamneront
gaming km août n'ont commis que beaucoup
me comprendront et que beaucoup me haïr
on mais je ne souhaite à personne de
devoir faire le choix que j'ai dû faire
tous vos plans puisque autour de mozart
aussi le caractère démocratique dû voter
de plus en plus contesté par la
communauté internationale l'union
européenne dénonce une élection ni
libres ni équitables et menace même de
prendre des sanctions à l'encontre de la
biélorussie
de son côté la pologne a proposé ce
mardi sa médiation entre le pouvoir et
l'opposition et des élections
incontestées qui font également réagir
en russie plusieurs dizaines
deux personnes se sont rassemblées
devant l'ambassade de biélorussie à
moscou est les manifestants souhaitent
protester contre les événements
biélorussie une témoigne également leur
soutien aux personnes blessées lors des
affrontements avec la police
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain point complet sur
l'actualité dans un peu plus de trente
minutes rester avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
dernier rapport du giec sur les océans
comme ça fout les jetons
on est dans une espèce de déni